so I think it's what we're talking about
we're talking about multiprocessor
systems ale is that we're talking about
systems where you have multiple CPUs to
write your software for so as people
said as we talked about things like the
keyboard have a CPU in them and all of
the times we're like the Atari or the
Auriga or even some of the original PCs
to process the keyboard and then just
send the data to the computer but that's
not usually a CPU that you're going to
program yourself right part of your
application to run on in the same way
most modern Intel motherboards the
management engines on runs on a CPU
embedded into the chipset that's running
on there and providing no one hacks it
then you're not gonna be running your
code on those it's it's a CPU it's doing
a task but it's not one we're going to
program with if it's not the central
processing unit it's an additional
processing unit is it still a CPU it's
the central processing unit of that
subsystem when we talk about CPU we're
talking about the central processing
units a bit at the heart of the system
doing things so people are rightly
pointing out that we have CPUs but we're
not gonna run our software to run on
them you can and if you look at some
weird bits of software they would
sometimes shove things down onto this
keyboard CPU and there's one virus on
the Atari ST that did that to stay a
memory and things but we're really
talking about the real central protein
where we're gonna write the software
that's going to run to do the tasks we
need and that's what we're talking about
but there is a class of effectively
processing units that you do find in
machines that are running part of our
software I mean the classic example of
that would be something like a
floating-point unit so these days our
CPUs whether it's an Intel chip or an
ARM chip or something often have
built-in support for doing
floating-point maps i adding 3.1415926
to some other random number and so on
after they're built in support for that
but they didn't originally if you look
at the original IBM PC I want the XT
behind me so let's take the lid off this
while we're doing that
so got a screwdriver built like a tank
[Music]
so inside the original PC and if we look
just down here next to the power supply
we'll see that if I take this card out
it's read-only the serial port at the
moment we can see what's going on HT 250
serial card eight bit I suppose said it
wasn't called that then so if we look
down here we'll see we've got on the
motherboard an Intel 8088 CPU that's the
main CPU in the original pcs what all
your PC is easing now derive from
whether it's a Macintosh or Windows
machine as oh they all have a chip which
pretty much still boots up like the
Intel 8088 did from 1983 but if you look
next to it you'll see there's an empty
socket with nothing plugged into it and
that was deliberately done there for two
reasons one where they designed the 8086
or the 8088
they deliberately built it in the way
knowing that they might want to add
support for what's called a
floating-point unit or FPU which is what
goes into that spare hole there and the
FPU was a chip that you could buy and
put into the PC or put into any machine
to have support for an after you to
handle the floating-point mathematics so
if you wanted to do add floating-point
numbers together you could either do it
by writing the software add the two
numbers together or you could do it by
having a floating-point chip inside your
computer and the floating-point chip
would then add the numbers together and
the advantage of that was you could
design the floating-point hardware to
run a lot of faster than you could just
write the software to do with the same
speed so you can build dedicated
hardware to add floating-point numbers
together in the same way you can build
dedicated hardware to add individual
numbers together which is what's inside
your CPU
so when they designed the 8088 chip and
what the 8086 chip
they left support him for this and so
there were some instructions which have
us if the opcode for that instruction
started with specific binary pattern
would allow a floating-point unit in the
system to take control reading the
values that are accessing from memory so
the CPU would work with the
floating-point unit to load the version
from memory and then the floating-point
unit would go off and do the
floating-point calculation in parallel
at the same time as a CPU kept money
doing into your stuff and so you did get
some sort of parallel pricing but it
wasn't a general-purpose process at this
time all it could do was floating point
stuff if it needed to access memory
it was the CPU that started things off
there was support in that to actually do
some fetch further values and so on
using direct memory access but in
general it was reliant on the CPU to do
a lot of the things so it's all
supported the CPU but gave you a
significant speed boost compared to
doing it all in software the nice thing
was is that the CPU if you run those
instructions would throw an exception so
you could write software then catch them
implement those instructions and
software but if the CPU if the FPU was
present it let the hardware do it in
parallel so you could get the best of
both worlds you could write the software
to use floating point Maps don't worry
about the floating point unit being
there if it is there you could then take
advantage of it
now the reason why the machines shipped
with an empty socket is because the
empty socket probably cost a few cents a
few pennies to put in but the CPU cost
about a hundred dollars I think minimum
if not more than that to put in the
machine so if you were just doing using
something like word processing on the
machine you don't need a floating-point
unit for most of the stuff you're doing
you would you wouldn't bother but if
you're doing something that did heavy
number crunching then you could drop the
floating-point unit into the machine
when it was built and you'd have one
that would work a lot better to do those
sort of operations now of course is the
machines developed through the 81 86 the
286 or 386 or 486 the software developed
and by the time the 40s it was popular
we had sort of fonts being drawn from
outline descriptions things which
actually involves doing floating-point
calculations and so eventually the
floating-point unit got built into the
CPUs themselves so it can have sort of
protesting units which aren't there as
general processing units but they
support the operations of the CPU do
they take some of the operations that
run on the CPU in software and they
don't add any new functionality there's
nothing that you can't do without them
but by doing it in Hardware you get a
speed boost by doing it in the case of
the floating-point unit on the original
PC or you could get the same for the
sort of Motorola machines you could
perhaps get a hundredfold increase in
the speed up to do those floating-point
operations
everything else rather at the same speed
but for the floating-point operations in
about 100 times faster which of course
meant if you've got a lot of them you
programs around about 100 times faster
if you weren't using them you didn't get
any benefit at all another one which is
quite interesting which you'd find in
things like some Atari STS and in most
amigas is what was called the blitter
chip and the bolita chip basically
implemented what was called the bit
block transfer routine or bit blit often
referred to and this was developed at
Xerox PARC in the 70s on the outter
machine I think it was and it was
basically a generalized algorithm for
copying blocks of memory round
particularly in the way that you want to
do raster graphics one of the things
that both the Amiga and the Atari had
and the only reason I'm looking at the
Atari here is because it had it as a
separate chip on the motherboard which
is annoyingly under the network part
Atari developed another chip which
implemented the bit block transfer
algorithm because he Vantage was then
that your main CPU wanted to copy a bit
of memory was set up this chip will just
appear as an i/o barrel and say to this
copy this bit of memory from this
address to this address combined with
what's already there using this sort of
combination and you could do some very
fancy graphics effects but the advantage
was whereas on the implement in software
you had to read the instruction for
memory that said load this value from
memory and then load it into a register
and then read those instruction says
load that value from memory and it was
loaded into it register and then do the
combination and write the value back out
this could just have a few Hardware
counters directly inside it that loading
the value from memory
loading the next value from memory
combined them wrote them back out into
memory so you could do it a lot faster
you could run every clock cycle doing
some useful work as opposed to some of
them having to fetch the instructions
that were doing what we needed to be
doing so by offloading it onto a
dedicated support
again just like with the FPU you're not
doing anything you can't do with the
main CPU but you're offloading it there
you having it run slightly faster and
then the CPU can get on with other
things although in this case it had to
wait for the British ship to finish it
but it was still faster than doing it
manually for all what the smallest of
operations the Amiga did the same thing
you had a British ship along with a
couple of other things which gave it the
advantages in terms of graphics of
course the problem had and which a
Charlie found is that as your CPU gets
faster you also have to make the blitter
chip faster or your CPU becomes much
faster than the British ships there's no
point of having on there so the Atari TT
for example which is a thirty two
megahertz 68030 as opposed to an eight
megahertz six eight thousand which also
had a cat that 68030 also had a cache
ran so much faster that the instructions
would be in the instruction cache so the
CPU could just fetch the data at full
speed from memory and write it back with
the combination done without the need
for the blitter chip and so you very
quickly you CPU gets faster you've got a
more general architecture you can do
whatever you need to do there and so
actually the British ship became
redundant in some of the Atari is pretty
soon after it was in lamented well they
didn't put a faster version into the
Falcon which can be useful in certain
modes acorn on the other hand when they
built the Archimedes they're roughly the
same sort of time as Commodore Amiga and
Atari ST have the blitter chips they
said well actually our CPUs so fast that
we don't need it there's no advantage to
it now but the same approach was taken
with graphics cards in computers that
you would end up with the graphics card
having support to do some of the basic
2d operations that Windows is wanting to
do and so on so rather than doing them
on the actual CPU you would hand that
control off to the graphics card to do
that things like copying the memory
about perhaps drawing a straight line
which you can very easily implement in
hardware and so you've got this balance
between do you you get your CPU to do
this as a general piece of software
which you can change and update
easily or do you hand this over to a
dedicated piece of hardware where you
can implement it in a way that's faster
and so on so for some things like the
graphics things
and floating points they very much now
been taken over by dedicated bits of
hardware if he's only delicately it's a
to Li harder and it more we get GPUs
which are effectively general-purpose
processing units but they're very much
configured and designed in a way that
makes them very amenable to doing
particularly 3d graphics processing but
also 2d graphics processing as well and
almost all CPUs these days and desktop
machines and laptops and so on have a
floating-point unit built-in because
we're doing stuff that needs those
floating-point so it makes sense in some
cases to have Hardware to do that in
other cases it makes more sense to have
it in the generalized nature of software
sort of be responsible for cleaning it
yourself you could be responsible for
managing the house and things or you can
employ someone else to do it on your
behalf so you can employ a cleaner or
someone to sort of clean the house well
then you haven't to do it yourself as
some people might choose to do it's the
same with the computer